they wanted me to have a smaller butt
but it's very hard to get rid of all
that
[Music]
what is a k-pop trainee someone who's a
product
of a korean entertainment company and
then you learn skills and the end goal
of a k-pop trainee is indefinitely
becoming a k-pop idol
so how do you become a k-pop trainee
usually it's by additions
i know like you sign up for one category
so i signed up for singing
most k-pop trainees range from as young
as like
10 years old i'm not korean when i
auditioned i didn't speak any korean
um i did speak chinese and english and i
think that they really liked that just
because it was kind of like the global
aspect
so why did i become a k-pop trainee this
is kind of embarrassing
but i was like a huge exo fan i actually
lived in shanghai before this so um
for like christmas break our parents
decided to like take us to korea
and i think it was then when i was like
oh my god like like just like kpop in
general like
they seem to like live such glamorous
lives and so i was like you know like
might as well
try it out since i was young i always
loved singing and dancing and acting
i actually came to korea for two
different reasons
one because i was like in love with exo
like sickly in love with exo
but the main reason that i came to korea
was because the language itself was just
so
freaking cool i went to a random casting
call for
people to do youtube reactions somehow
some way
it came across the desk of some ceo that
was working for this
entertainment company he contacted me
and
after a month of going back and forth i
eventually
signed with this company what is a k-pop
trainee's daily schedule
this varies between like kind of what
you're doing like are you like right
before a debut or are you still early on
around 6 00 am i would start to
exercise i would go to a class with my
korean tutor
and we would be studying korean for
around four hours
when i was in korea i didn't go to
school i took a gap year so at least for
my
day-to-day basis i maybe like woke up at
around 10
i went to the studio and
from like 10 to like afternoon usually
you just work on like self
self training go to a dance studio
to practice i would have to meet with my
manager
so we can have dinner and discuss what
needed to be done
my stylist would show up to go through
my closet
put new clothes in kind of guide me on
what was required of me
usually at night we have like group
dance lessons and singing lessons from
then
to um like midnight or like even later
we like go back into individual training
maybe get around
three to four hours of sleep what is a
k-pop trainee's typical diet
wow i have been thin my whole life i
just
have like a little bit more curves they
they wanted me to have a smaller butt
but
it's very hard to get rid of all that
what my company and i talked about as
far as dieting went we
just kind of agreed that i wasn't going
to be pigging out all the time
usually we aren't allowed to eat carbs
when we can but like it's not really
recommended so a lot of kpop trainees we
would substitute it with
sweet potatoes hard-boiled eggs
a lot of vegetables usually like cherry
tomatoes cucumbers
we had to weigh ourselves every two
three days
in front of like the teachers in front
of the other trainees are korean beauty
standards
imposed on trainees yes because we're in
korea the beauty standards just like an
asian general is just like
insane and i think trainees are like the
epitome of that like we have to be like
the skinniest of the skinniest
they would be trying to push me more
towards a korean style
with my clothes like my stylist the
first day that i moved into my new home
and she threw away
all of my clothes but captioning not
they're available more harshly i think
for females more
of like criticism is usually like verbal
criticism while like male it's more like
physical
maybe like if we didn't lose enough
weight like for females it's like they
would like
say like oh you're fat you kind of try
to humiliate you
before it's mail it's like okay do like
20 push-ups right now can trainees have
social media accounts this is a funny
one okay technically
no but i had one as long as they don't
find it it's fine i was not allowed to
have social media
i remember my current instagram i
deleted
all of the pictures can k-pop trainees
date i
remember part in my contract that said
like you know i can't have a boyfriend
which is
you know standard it's mostly forbidden
i've known people who've like dated the
like male trainees in their company
and that didn't end well the male
trainee was like fired how much do
kpop trainees get paid i got paid zero
bucks made absolutely nothing
my company at that time i paid for my
housing they paid for my food i had an
allowance i had
pretty much my life handed to me how
kpop trainees work is that like you
dance you sing
and then like obviously the studio
there's like a renting fee and all that
but the company pays for it because
technically they're investing in you
like when you debut hopefully and then
hopefully you get make a lot of money
you have to pay back the company
how do you go from training to idle well
takes a heck of a lot of practice
usually the company maybe has like 20 30
girls and then every month there's like
a monthly exam
and then they cut like a few girls each
month you have to be able to
withstand all of the companies like
demands
rules schedules you have to be okay with
not being able to see your family
and then usually right before a debut i
think a lot of them
would have like free concerts where like
trainees like travel around and like
give free concerts
just kind of like to build a fan base
you have to be okay with having your
privacy
invaded 24 7. in the recent years
ever since like produce 101 i think a
big thing was like these competition
shows where you can like gain exposure
i think that's pretty popular where like
trainees go through that before they
debut
you have to be sure that this is
something that you truly want
and not just because it seems fun in the
moment what do trainees do
if they don't debut i know a lot of my
friends who haven't debuted
they're into like musicals now or they
go like go back to college
or some don't stop which in my case
that seems to be true for me i left
just because i didn't finish high school
and so i was like i need at least a high
school diploma in our society
today i ended up just making my own
music
i didn't realize that i didn't need a
company to do what i love to do
another reason why i left was just
because i didn't really like the
trainee idol culture it was
a little toxic in my opinion you just
you really have to be very very careful
in
any entertainment industry whether it's
koreas whether it's america's
some people train so long and then they
never
end up debuting it's crazy to me that
how like some girls they are willing to
give up everything
the most valuable thing i think i've
gained from the training experience
definitely like taught me how to be
independent taught me like what the
entertainment industry is like
i am so much more confident and i feel
like i had to develop some thick skin
and i learned how to be a better person
from the isolation so i'm very happy for
that and i don't regret any part of my
experiences it is right for some people
but i don't think it's like right for
everyone
not right for every k-pop fan it's not
right for me
you